[Music]
black Americans paid for the right to
vote with blood and bruises
[Music]
what started out as a peaceful protest
from Selma to Montgomery Alabama in
March of 1965 ended in horrific violence
months later the Voting Rights Act was
passed black Americans are now
guaranteed the right to vote but if you
follow that same trail today from Selma
to Montgomery on highway 80 you'll find
an area of extreme rural poverty where
families who live in the epicenter of
the civil rights movement are still
being denied access to basic human
rights
[Music]
there are parts of Lowndes County
Alabama so impoverished and neglected
that people don't have access to
sanitation pamela rush is one of those
people behind her mobile home is a pool
of human excrement that's because she
has a straight pipe going directly from
her toilet into the backyard why can't
you because they get stopped delaying so
be stopped do
because you have no something I have no
certain system if make me feel baby
because I don't want my stuff just
coming at him running in the ground many
homes in Lowndes County are too
scattered for a central wastewater
facility an estimated 80 percent of
residents have to pay out of pocket to
get rid of their own waste and with
nearly a third of the community living
below the poverty line people like
Pamela have resorted to straight piping
into fields yards and ditches yes I
called this America's dirty secret I
think that this is a problem that has
gone on for years Katherine Coleman
flowers grew up in Lowndes County and
has spent the last 16 years trying to
find a solution to the sanitation crisis
a lot of what is happening in Lowndes
County is environmental racism allows
sixes Thank You sixties we didn't we had
to provide our own water people had
their own wheels and then when the USDA
started providing water to families in
rural communities they left out the
sanitation part so as a result a lot of
these areas intentionally were I think
victims of benign neglect you know the
lack of investment in those communities
to put the infrastructure in place to
keep the population poor and a lot of
these populations are largely people of
color
Lowndes County sits in the middle of a
region in Alabama known as the Black
Belt that's because the majority of the
population is made up of black Americans
but it also earned the nickname because
of its rich dense clay soil our soils
were the reason that people came here in
the first place
you know and settled this area they came
here because that they had won out the
soils and the Carolinas and the
of Alabama decided that they wanted to
expand and put their plantations and
bring their slaves here and the people
that are in Lowndes County a lot of us
including myself are the senders of
those slaves that were brought to this
area to work the ground because the
ground is good for playing but it's not
good for on-site wastewater treatment
here's the reason most on-site septic
systems rely primarily on the soil
itself to treat wastewater the affluent
flows out of drain holes where soil
particles and microbes filter out
bacteria but in hard clay soil water
can't really move and that means
wastewater can't be filtered properly
so while an ordinary septic tank might
cost between five and ten thousand
dollars the ones often needed to handle
the soil in Lowndes County can cost
anywhere from six to thirty thousand
dollars the annual per capita income
here is $18,000 yes Lowndes County and I
agree is the poorest County in the
United States you're talking about
poverty that's not for the health
department of Bix Cheri Bradley is the
director of environmental services at
the Alabama Health Department between
1996 and 2001 24 people were issued
arrest warrants in Lowndes County for
septic system violations brought forward
by her department in recent years the
department has stopped taking people in
this county to court but it continues to
cite homeowners which could lead to a
misdemeanor and fine sherry says the
department's role in all of this is only
regulatory we still write notice of
violation I don't know why people call
it criminalizing
when you get a ticket for speeding does
that criminalize it it's saying that you
broke broken the law that's not a
strategy that's that's what we do we we
regulate the permitting the installation
and the use of septic tank systems we
don't criminalize anybody in 2015 the UN
said access to sanitation is a human
right that requires not only access to a
toilet but also the safe collection
management and disposal of feces in
wastewater if the person refuses to put
in a system it goes to court the judge
decide what to do period it sounded by
hands no way Lowndes County is just one
piece of a larger picture that shows a
pattern of neglect and marginalization
of low-income rural communities across
America nearly half a million households
in the u.s. lack access to proper
sanitation Katherine believes the legacy
of slavery racism and segregation cannot
be separated from the current situation
the institutions were set up based on
racism in some cases I think that
institutional racism is still in place
and that's one of the reasons why we
have these problems the history of this
area is entrenched in white supremacy
and plantation power the equal justice
initiative documented 14 lynchings in
Lowndes County a memorial was just
raised a 20 minute drive away in
Montgomery to honor the thousands killed
in lynchings across the u.s.
in the 1950s it earned the nickname
bloody lounge because of the violence
and terror inflicted on black people by
white residents who wanted to maintain
segregation guess the backdrop of all of
that Lowndes County has although it has
changed and their black elected
officials in place now you see where the
sanitation in the cities where there is
sanitation or a large municipal system
it generally stops at where the black
community starts or people have problems
in the areas of town where black people
have traditionally live these
inequalities spatial racial income and
property intersect with something even
more alarming the resurgence of
parasitic disease linked to poor
sanitation Katherine and a team of
researchers from the Baylor College of
Medicine conducted a study that found
two in five participants had intestinal
parasites primarily hookworm something
most experts assumed had disappeared in
the u.s. the Alabama State Health
Department refuses to acknowledge the
validity of the test results we are yet
to find a person a person's name a
person is receiving hell we are yet to
find anything like that and we've looked
there is no evidence of hookworms in
Alabama the unfortunate part is that the
government should be partnering with us
on finding real solutions instead of
trying to pretend like this problem does
not
the house paint fit the Libyan Coast
element stuff coming my house oh and I
got holes everywhere in the house and my
own dad stole my watch it was got
rolling up and your leaking water right
now so I have to squeeze hose out and
hang them up in the house before the gas
of the whiskey we're gonna continue
doing what we're doing and that is to
enforce the law and be fair about it and
that's all we can do when I talked about
these institutions that are in place
these structures that are in place that
the undergirds and supports poverty and
until we change that it doesn't matter
who the face of it is or who's in charge
it could be somebody who looks like me
it doesn't matter until these structural
things change we're going to continue to
create what we've created and then I can
do
I can pray
[Music]
cuz I'm Hannah
you
[Music]